one of the best things Jordan Peterson
said I had him at an event and he was
talking about his next book coming up
Jordan Peterson talked about if you
really want to know if people have your
back or not say some good and say
something bad about yourself and just
watch their reaction
if you say something bad about yourself
that happened and you look at them and
that you can tell there's a part of
celebration going on oh wow you can tell
where they're at but if you say good
things about yourself and you see how
what they turn into you can also kind of
tell where they're at but you will know
more about them if you say bad things
then you will know versus when you say
good things uh I look I'm I'm a I'm an
extremely logical and paranoid guy
skeptical guy and I'm not looking to
have a billion great relationships I I
I'm looking to have a handful to ten
phenomenal valuable relationships in
life outside of my family meaning
there's there's no relationship more
important you want to have them with
your kids your wife your family all that
that's very important but outside of
that friends non-blood five to ten if
you got five like tens in your life dude
you have the same amount of wealth as
Elon Musk has if you have five tens like
ride or die type of buddies in your life
great you're the richest man in the
world I like that yeah you're the
richest man in the world now if you can
make some money as well you can enjoy
the money with your friends yeah yeah
because yeah it sucks when you don't
have the money to enjoy those special
moments together you know so uh uh uh
again we're gonna see what's gonna
happen here with this guy I'll add to
that like if my mom watches this clip
she's gonna like fail right or ten of
Tears my mom the number one lesson she
would tell me as a kid is like
in order to have a friend you need to be
a friend and like I say this all the
time I don't have any hobbies in my life
I don't go rock climbing I don't do I
don't collect baseball cards I got
nothing going on about all the stamp
collection
I value friendship I like hanging out
with my boys I like making money I like
hanging out with pretty girls I'm a very
simple dude but to pass to basically
what Pat's saying is there's a couple
quotes we can talk about right here but
essentially if like value those who
um will support you when they have
nothing to gain
that like essentially like
um
who will have you in your life when you
have nothing to offer other than
yourself just being there for you
there's a famous quote by Oprah what's
I'm gonna read the quote she says um
um
lots of people want to ride with you in
the limo
but what you want is someone who will
take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down so when you have nothing to
offer other than your company that is a
true sign of a friendship like the guy
the the guy that you went to lunch with
at rafi's place I don't know the
relationship but was he using you for
something or what was the what was the
situation it was a competitive
environment yeah it was like Hey because
what frustrated him the most is the fact
that I won without getting a college
degree and all of them went and got the
college degrees and to them to their
families every time I would go around
their families it was like when are you
going to get your degree when are you
going to get your degree such and such
got his degree such and such God is good
when are you going to get your degree
when are you going to get your it was
always that conversation I'm like yeah
guys I'm not going to get my degree and
then when I blew up after telling them
what I was gonna do that was when it was
the end of it they were not happy uh
about the level of success that came
afterwards but some of the guys one guy
was freaking straight up he says look
took me to Conrad's shout out to Adrian
this guy took me to conrades and said
look Pat I got to just be honest with
you I thought you were going to be the
biggest failure out of all of our
friends really I thought you were going
to be the biggest failure I thought you
were going to do nothing with your life
and the fact that you have has shocked
the hell out of me but I just won't tell
you I'm proud of you man that's awesome
guess what I was like dude respect good
for you I I you know what I appreciate
it he's got a great life today he's
successful he's doing good for himself
but you know I I learned some of them
were more up to games behind closed
doors versus the other way around hey
Pat has money you pay for it hey let's
go to Pat's place for the party but hey
we're doing a gathering at the house
let's remind everybody about Pat you
know because I might make you
uncomfortable and all the people that
have all the fancy degrees get together
and I'm not there I'm totally fine with
that I'm very comfortable in my own skin
all I'm saying is
you're going to know as you succeed
if some of the guys that were you know
maybe ahead of you at the time and now
you're ahead of them that messes what a
lot of people says got you and I like
the fact that you said that because I I
honestly was like I'm trying to figure
out if your life is just chilling and
you're going like this because I haven't
fallen Fallen I've had I've had bad
stuff happen in my life and I've had
friends there I'll go back to when you
were the Airman of the year what are you
talking about yeah there's a lot of guys
that we're not happy that we've been
here oh yeah haters but I mean that's
what you're saying is the opposite is is
nothing here you were nothing when
you're children who are those snakes
believe me a lot of the people that were
ahead of you in comedy who have never
had a video get a couple hundred million
views are sitting there saying freaking
guys I'm seeing them everywhere right
now you secretly some of them are not
celebrating you don't see it yeah I got
you yeah but just be patient just be
patient you're gonna you're gonna learn
a lot so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]